Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: He is not allowed to
use SCP-705 for personal gain!
The Play-Doh toy soldiers are highly entertaining
to watch, and it’s understandable to be
curious about their potential applications,
but Dr. Bright has taken it too far.
He used the tiny soldiers to plant hidden
cameras and microphones in his colleague’s
offices.
Not only is this a violation of their privacy,
but it’s also just plain creepy, and it’s
unfair to make SCP-705 instances accomplices
to your bad behavior!
They didn’t know what they were signing
on to do, and if they’d known the hidden
surveillance equipment was intended for blackmail
or for stealing a secret lasagna recipe that’s
been in Dr. Giotta’s family for generations,
they never would have agreed.